well this morning we were talking about
what is at stake in the midterm
elections and a buzzword you've probably
heard a lot recently that word is woke
what's that all about well the polls
show something here is going on a recent
CBS poll showed that more than
two-thirds of Americans two-thirds
believe their rights and freedoms are
what's on the line in November that's an
even greater share of Voters and are
worried about their financial well-being
and nearly half of those surveys said
that our culture and way of life is at
stake again in November in the midterms
the result is an election that's about
different policies yes but also very
different visions of what America is
right now and what America should be in
the future and perhaps nowhere is that
more evident than in the state of
Florida
[Music]
in the battle to Define America Governor
Ron DeSantis has what amounts to his
very own fight song he stands up
plus a campaign ad inspired by Top Gun
when they fire you fire back with
overwhelming force and if there's one
political Target he seems to favor above
all others it's this one woke is the new
religion of the left we're not going to
let this state descend into some type of
woke dumpster fire we will never ever
surrender to the woke agenda in fact the
whole Florida Republican party seems to
be taking on what it calls the woke left
including Senator Rick Scott who
released a 12-point plan for all
Republicans in the Senate to rescue
America from vocal leadists woke
indoctrination and a new religion of
wokeness but hold on a minute what does
woke even mean to you what does it mean
to be woke
I have I mean I don't know what the
definition woke so so much is I didn't
do know that I think most people don't
want to be lectured by companies so I
think that's sort of what people think
awoke or don't be put it differently in
in what way is the woke left in your
view a threat to America itself
well when our schools don't teach our
kids that we're the greatest country in
the world when they disrespect our flag
when kids are told that they don't have
a shot because of their skin color I
don't think that's the country I grew up
in Merriam-Webster back in 2017 defined
woke as aware of and actively attentive
to important facts and issues like race
and social justice
but use of the word has broadened into
complex debates about abortion history
and identity not to mention whether
corporations should get involved in any
of it the right began to use it as a
kind of dog whistle
for anyone on the left and anything
that's smacked of progressive politics
James Davison Hunter is a professor of
Sociology at the University of Virginia
he says the new war over woke isn't
really new at all we have been winning
the cultural War the cultural war is
Raging across our land instead he says
it's a continuation of the culture wars
a concept he first popularized in a book
way back in 1991. why did you call it a
war well from the vantage point of the
actors involved
it felt like war and there was this
sense that what is at stake is what I
cherish most about my life and about the
world I live in and the world I hope to
leave to my children no small thing and
cumulatively it becomes a struggle to
define the meaning of America
and that struggle continues today
worrying Hunter because the fight has
gotten meaner he says and our ability to
talk to one another has broken down
politics and theory is supposed to be
how we work things out exactly so we
don't come to violence exactly is
politics working anymore that's part of
the problem our politics is now so
driven by culture when people no longer
see a way out politically
they'll choose alternative strategies to
pursue their agenda I don't think
there's any question that there will be
more violence going forward
more violence he predicts along with
more elections in which the results are
not accepted by all sides and that is
the biggest threat to America at least
according to democratic Florida state
representative Anna escamani what does
woke mean to you it just means being
aware of your history her Orlando office
is filled with pictures and slogans that
tell you right away where she stands on
the issues and hint at why she's so dug
in to fight is there any room for
compromise I mean it's very difficult to
compromise on a policy that erases the
history of people of color and I've had
this conversation with Republican
leadership on abortion specifically of
you know where's the compromise and the
reality is that it's very hard to
compromise when you're basically telling
me that I am less than and I do not have
the same rights as as you and then on
bending attitude is there on the
Republican side as well they're trying
to take freedom and they want control
that's exactly what they do that's what
they do and with socialism they they
take they ultimately take away your
freedoms it sounds really nice I mean
but in the end it's it's evil yet a lot
of Americans believe this is all a big
distraction and that includes Charlie
Crist who's running against DeSantis for
governor in a statement to CBS News he
says every election Republicans invent
some new Boogeyman instead of trying to
solve problems and make people's lives
better but Professor Hunter warns we
shouldn't underestimate just how
important these issues are to so many of
our fellow Americans if we just think
that these are side issues that these
things actually don't really matter
we're missing what is most combustible
about the culture war and most
combustible about the moment that we're
living in right now
um so I think the professor makes such a
good point there these These are
sometimes talked about as distractions
when what really matters is the economy
or health care but these are the issues
that are core to who people are who we
are as a country and the Lord woke
specifically came out of black American
culture it was a way to talk about
racial inequality it's broadened a lot
since then and it's become essentially a
by word for all right and wrong in our
public life right I've always thought it
was uh hyper Awareness on specific
issues to one person
um but then you you kind of extrapolate
that and you say okay what's important
to me because it's all relative to
what's important to a specific man or
woman or a group or a political party so
woke has been taken and just stretched
out so thin and it can be used in so
many different ways yeah I love the
person the professor is actually saying
do not minimize this this is very
important I hope he's not correct though
when he says you can expect more
violence going forward but I see signs
of that already Tony oh absolutely so
that Professor who's at a very fancy a
place at University of Virginia The
Institute for the advanced studies and
culture uh in the 90s wrote a book
called before the shooting starts and it
was about how culture wars always
precede shooting Wars and in particular
he was talking about violence around
abortion and he came up with that title
five days before the first right-wing
attack on an abortion clinic in America
so he's very good at anticipating what
people internalize as motivation for
violence and what he's saying right now
is when there's no compromise one side
is saying evil and the other side's
saying you're not you're denying my
Humanity those are terms for violence
but it was interesting that Senator
Scott seems to use the word woke a lot
but then when you asked him what is it
what does it mean seem like a slippery
because it means everything and nothing
right now in this country that's the
bottom line it's well said